ON MILITARY VETERANSFOR TO COME
TO ORDER WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
HIS SUBCOMMITTEE UNTIL WE GET OF
A QUORUM FOR GOOD AFTERNOON ONCE
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMAN AND-
WE WILL- READ SIMILAR THINGS ARE
SO IMPORTANT FOR YOU. AND THIS
AFTERNOON WILL CONTINUE TO TAKE
SOME PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE
ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN RISK THE
SENATE CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE
PUBLIC AND HAS PROVIDED ACCESS
TO BOTH IN PERSON AND
TELECONFERENCES PATIENT FOR THE
FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS AND YOUR
SAFETY. BRAWL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPATION TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
. AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE SIX THREE. AND THE
ACCESS CODE NUMBER IS. SEVEN
THREE SIX TWO EIGHT THREE THREE.
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTION MUTED. WE'RE HOLDING
OUR COMMITTEE HEARING HERE IN
THE- STREET BUILDING I ASK ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO E
PRESIDENT ROOM TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED TWO WEEKENDS ESTABLISH A
QUORUM AND BEGAN OUR HEARING.
THANK YOU. BEFORE WE CONTINUE
TODAY'S AGENDA LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM AND I SEE WE DON'T HAVE
ONE- BUT- WILL GO AHEAD AND CALL
THE ROLL ANYWAY. RUNNING A-
CONSULTANT. WE'LL WE'LL SKIP IT
AND WILL COME BACK- AS I
MENTIONED THE QUORUM IS NOT BEEN
ESTABLISHED WE HAVE WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM CHAU WILL CONTINUE
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE. WE HAVE
ELEVEN MEASURES ON THE COUNTER
TODAY. NINE OR CONSENT DO WE
HAVE A MOTION WE DON'T WE CAN'T
DO THAT UNTIL WE HAVE A QUORUM
THE CALENDAR AND LET'S SEE. ONE
SO WE'LL WAIT TILL WE GET TO A
QUORUM BEFORE WE CAN TAKE ROLE.
THE CORRECT SO LET'S GO AHEAD
AND DO THE VERY FIRST ONE. YEAH
SO I AM GOING TO SIT IN FOR
CENTER EGGMAN AND PRESENT HER
BILL THIRTEEN ELEVEN SO I'M
GOING TO HAND IT TO MY
COLLEAGUE- JOSH NEWMAN. IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE. GOOD MORNING SIR
BETTER SEARCH RIGHT ON BEHALF OF
THE CENTRE EGGMAN PLEASE PROCEED
WITH SB THIRTEEN ELEVEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AT THANK YOU
MEMBERS I'M PRESENTING SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN ELEVEN TODAY ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR EGGMAN. AS SHE
HAS AGREED TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. THIS BILL. BUILDS OFF
THE SUCCESS OF AB THIRTY TO
TWELVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN
AND SEEKS TO EXPAND CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS FOR OUR SERVICE
MEMBERS AND VETERANS STATEWIDE.
THIS BILL CAME TOGETHER THROUGH
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND MILITARY PERSONNEL
JAG LEGAL ASSISTANCE ATTORNEYS.
COMMAND FINANCIAL COUNSELORS AND
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE MILITARY
AND VETERANS COMMUNITY. THIS
BILL STRENGTHENS PROTECTIONS
RELATED TO MILITARY DISCOUNTS
PRIVACY PROTECTION RETURN OF
SECURITY DEPOSITS BY OUR-
PROTECTIONS AND- DEFERRAL OF
INTEREST AMONG OTHER THINGS.
THIS BILL WILL ALSO IMPOSE
ENHANCED CIVIL PENALTIES FOR
VIOLATIONS OF THE UNFAIR
COMPETITION LAW. AGAINST SERVICE
MEMBERS AND VETERANS EACH
SECTION OF THIS BILL COMES FROM
CONVERSATION AND MILITARY
MEMBERS AND CASES INVESTIGATED
AND TRIED BY THE OFFICE OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL. AND REFLECT
REAL LIFE ISSUES AND BAD ACTORS
THAT SEEK TO EXPLOIT SERVICE
MEMBERS THIS BILL RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN STATE
JUDICIARY AND HAS RECEIVED ZERO
NO VOTES. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE-
IN AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME I
WILL GO AHEAD AND ASK AND I
THINK WE'RE READY. WITH US TODAY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS NICK
ACTORS IN ANTHONY LIU ON BEHALF
OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE. HELLO GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS ANTHONY LUPA DEPUTY AG IN THE
OFFICE OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
FOR. EIGHTY ROB BONTA IS THE
PROUD SPONSOR OF THIS
LEGISLATION. WE WANT TO THANK
CENTER EIGHT MEN AND- ATKINS FOR
THEIR LEADERSHIP AND AUTHORING
SB THIRTEEN ELEVEN. THE MILITARY
AND VETERAN CONSUMER PROTECTION
ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO- THIS
BILL BUILDS UPON EXISTING LAN
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL LEGAL AND
FINANCIAL PROTECTIONS. FOR
ACTIVE DUTY AND RESERVE
COMPONENT SERVICE MEMBERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES. THE LEGAL
PROTECTIONS ARE INTENDED TO
ADDRESS THE UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES
OF MILITARY SERVICE AND ALLOW
SERVICE MEMBERS. TO FOCUS ON
PERFORMING THEIR MISSIONS ARE
PROTECTING THEIR FELLOW SERVICE
MEMBERS AND I COMING HOME SAFELY
TO THEIR FAMILIES AND- THANK YOU
TO THE WORK OF THE COMMITTEE.
AND THE CHAIR FOR A SUMMARIZING
THE BILL INTRODUCED IN THE BILL
AND THE BILL IS SPONSORED BY
SUPPORTED BY A BROAD RANGE OF.
CONSUMER ADVOCATES AND MILITARY
GROUPS AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY THINKING IT WOULD
THANK YOU MISTER LIU I DON'T SEE
ON OUR NOTES HERE NICHOLAS
ACRES. SENIOR ASSISTANT ATTORNEY
GENERAL FOR CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
ALSO WITH US VIA THE TELEPHONE
CONFERENCE ONE. THAT'S RIGHT AND
I THINK NICK IS HERE TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL IS THE ANSWERING
SERVICE THAT'S RIGHT THANK YOU
NOW THAT'S GOOD TO AT THIS POINT
WILL MOVE ON TO A WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. OF SB THIRTEEN ELEVEN
WHO ARE HERE WITH US IN. THE
COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM. SEEING
NONE- WE WILL MOVE TO TELL. I
MISSED MY- GIVE YOU PLEASE GIVE.
ANY IS IN IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN ELEVEN ON THE
CONFERENCE LINE. THANK YOU TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE. AGAIN ONE VOEPEL
ZERO. WE HAVE TWO LINES IN Q.
OUR FIRST LINE IS TWO THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE PROCEED. ONE TWO
THREE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEETING TO MAKE A COMMENT ON
THAT AS WELL I'M SORRY. THANK
YOU. WE'RE GOING OUT TO LINE.
TWO OH SIX TWO ZERO SIX. DANIEL
COULD CARRY ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IMPORT. IN THIS
MATTER IF YOU COULD PLEASE Q.
ONE ONE ONE MORE TIME FORCE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT OR THIRTEEN
ELEVEN. PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO FOR THE LINES INTO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION- ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TRY IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE. HEARING
ROOM. SEEING NONE MISS MODERATE
IF YOU COULD PLEASE Q. THE
CONFERENCE LINE FOR ANYONE IS
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. TO S. B. ELEVEN
THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU THE STATE
UP THERE DILLON PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. IN OPPOSITION TO BILL
THIRTEEN ELEVEN PRESS ONE AND
THEN THERE OFFICE TIME. THANK
YOU KNOW LINE THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
HEARING ROOM- WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM- I DO NOT HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS- MR ARCHULETA ON
BEHALF OF CENTER EGGMAN IF YOU'D
LIKE TO CLOSE YES- AS CHAIR
THANK YOU SO MUCH. SO ON BEHALF
CENTER EGGMAN I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I WILL. VERY GOOD I WILL
HAND THE GO BACK TO CENTER
ARCHULETA. THAT WILL TAKE THAT
VOTE WHEN WE DO HAVE A QUORUM.
WE'RE GONNA DO YOURS. THE NEXT
BILL. RIGHT THE HONOR OF SHARING
THIS VERY ONCE AGAIN- THERE IS
SENATE TO LET THEM- IT'S AN ARCH
ALETTA- IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOUMISTER CHAIR.
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS THOSE WHO
WERE WATCHING AND ON THE WAY.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT SEEKS TO INCREASE THE
MAXIMUM. CONTRACT AMOUNT FOR
SERVICES AND INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY CONTRACTS AWARDED.
THROUGH THE SMALL BUSINESS. AND
DISABLED VETERANS BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE OPTION. FROM TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND IT MOVING
IT UP TO FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND.
THE SMALL BUSINESS DISABLED
VETERANS. BUSINESS ENTERPRISE
CONTRACTING OPTION. IS
STREAMLINED IS IT STREAMLINED
PROCUREMENT PROCESS FOR
CERTIFIED SMALL BUSINESSES. OR
DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESSES
ENTERPRISES. THE OPTION ALLOWS
STATE DEPARTMENTS TO CONTRACT
DIRECTLY WITH A CERTIFIED SMALL
BUSINESS DISABLED VETERANS
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE. FOR GOODS
SERVICES. OR I. T. AS LONG AS
THE AGENCY ALSO OBTAINS COACH
FROM TWO SMALL BUSINESS. STABLE
VETERANS ENTERPRISE. OUR STATE
SMALL. INVESTORS BUSINESSES HAVE
FACED UNIQUE CHALLENGES. THROUGH
THE PANDEMIC. N. MANY HAVE BEEN
FORCED TO CLOSE OUR DOORS AND
LAY OFF STAFF. SINCE THE LAST
INCREASE THE SMALL BUSINESS
DISABLED VETERAN. BUSINESS
OPTION WAS BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
AND NINE. BUSINESSES IN THE
STATE HAVE STRUGGLED WITH.
INFLATION AND INCREASED EXPENSES
DRIVING UP THE COST OF GOODS AND
SERVICES. SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT. INCREASES THE
MAXIMUM CONTRACT AWARD. FROM TWO
FIFTY TWO AND FIFTY THOUSAND TO
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND. DOLLARS
TO ALLOW SMALL BUSINESSES AND
VETERANS OWNED. BUSINESSES TO BE
COMPETITIVE. WITH BIDDING FOR
STATE CONTRACTS WILL ALSO
INCREASING THE AMOUNT. THEY CAN
BENEFIT FINANCIALLY FOR DOING
BUSINESSES. WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THIS LEVELS THE
PLAINFIELD INCREASE IN THE
OPTION TO FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR
WOULD HELP OUR SMALL BUSINESS OR
SMALL BUSINESSES WITH THE
INCREASED COST OF GOODS WHILE
ALSO ENSURING THAT THRESHOLD IS
APPROPRIATE. TO BE BEST UTILIZED
BY THE STATE'S DEPARTMENTS WITH
SMALL BUSINESSES AND VETERANS
OWNED COMPANIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE COBIT NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
EQUITABLE RECOVERY REQUIRES
EMPHASIS ON THESE SMALL
BUSINESSES AND GROUPS. ALIKE
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE HAS PASSED A SERIES
OF BILLS A RECOMMENDED BY THE
STATE AUDITOR TO IMPROVE AND
STRENGTHEN THE OVERSIGHT OF THE
PROGRAM. SENATE BILL FORTY
SEVENTY EIGHT WILL HELP SUPPORT
LOCAL BUSINESSES AND DEVELOP- A
WHERE WITH ALL TO OPEN DOORS FOR
DISABLED VETERANS BUSINESSES
WHILE STRENGTHENING IN THE
PROGRAM- AND OUR LOCAL ECONOMY.
ON THE LINE I HAVE JEFF WENT AS
WITH VETERANS STRONG USA AND
MADELINE SCENE WITH THE
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA. AND OF COURSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME-
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU SEARCH
WHAT IT SO. IS IT I SHOW
DIFFERENT ORDER- MISSTATEMENT MS
KLEIN OR MR FUENTES. TAKE YOUR
PICK OF THE TELECONFERENCE MY
WE'RE LOOKING FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
. THANK YOU GET UP THERE JOURNAL
WHAT ABOUT GERMAN HELLO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ESPERANZA LET
THE MONEY THAT. I'VE BEEN A
CERTIFIED SMALL IS NEEDED ABOUT
HOW MUCH YOU FELT NINE I'M A
BETTER ACTRESS LEAD VETERANS
TRONG U. S. STATUS MANTRA IS
IMPROVING THE LIVES OF VETERANS
THROUGH LEGISLATION WE REPRESENT. ONE THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
EIGHTY SEVEN D. V. D. THEY- TAKE
WITH THEM ABOUT OUR LEGISLATION
TO OUR PARTNERS. EXACTLY
VETERANS AFFAIRS BECAUSE BUT THE
FACT WORK THE US BETTER AND
BETTER SO ALLIANCE UP ME FIVE
YEARS AGO WE DID WORK WITH FIJI
ACT ON- AUG CREATING A REPORTING
PLATFORM THE CAPTURES BOTH PRIME. AND SUBCONTRACTOR. AND CURRENT
WE HAVE A INTEL THREE HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE PER TO FIVE FROM.
ONE THOUSAND SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
OF ARE V. D. HE'S WITH SIX
EPISODES OF FOG IN OUR HARPER.
THREE ALL SIX OF THE ADDRESS THE
SPEND OF FROM THE PRO FOR THREE
YEARS NOW THE SYSTEM THAT THE DO
WITH THE BUSINESS DID YOU D. E.
OPTION. AND THE OTHER WILL WORK
UP A THE HOUSE FORTY MINUTES
WELL FOR DEPARTMENTS EIGHT SMALL
BECAUSE UP TO AND SEVENTY YOU
COULD BE. OFF AT WORK AT HIGHER
THAN THE NINE THREE THE UNITS
SMALL BOATS OFTEN KICKED THREE
USING THE V. D. R. THAT
THROUGHOUT EIGHT CAN YOU TELL
NINETEEN. INCREASE AT THE
HUNDRED THOUSAND WILL ONLY HELP
THE PROCUREMENT TO BE MORE
EFFICIENT AND MORE. IN THE- BOB
MINIMIZE THE OTHER STRESS OF THE
I'VE BEEN WITH YOU DOZENS OF
RESPONSIBLE ONE THE- AWESTRUCK-
THAT. THE STORE D. V. D. E. A
MUST. THE OF THE SUB. DUE TO THE
INCREASED OFF DURING THE OF
WEDDING ONE OR MORE OF MORE
BUSINESS D. V. OB AND THE
IMMEDIATELY ELEVATE. BUSINESS
OWNER TO CONSIDER PRIOR ON.
STATUS.
OUR TO OUR- INCREDIBLE NEW
REPORTING THREE TO FIVE FEET
YEAH THERE WAS NO WAY TO ATTRACT
UP ON PRACTICE BRENT BUT WE NOW
HAVE THAT. WE HAVE A CLEAR.
PICTURE OF THE INCREDIBLE THAT
SMALL DVD PROGRAM AT THE PRIME
AND SUBCONTRACT LEVEL BROUGH
ARGUE ANNUAL REPORT. WE CAN SEE
THIS PROGRAM AS A WHOLE IS
WORKING PERFECTLY OF EVIDENCE BY
THE NEW ANNUAL REPORTS A WHITE
INCREASINGLY OFTEN THE FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND WILL GIVE US
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PERFORM AT
THE PRIME CONTRACTOR LEVEL. ARE
ALL STATE PROJECTS- WELCOME NOT
ALL TV E. WHY TO DO BECAUSE
WE'RE THE STATE CAL. THE PUBLIC
BIT AND YOU. PROGRAM HAVE BEEN
SICK. THAT ARE. DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THE- CHALLENGE. UC YEAH.
ALL YOU. ARE THESE HE YOU SEE A
SCHOOL BUILT FOR HAVE A DOCTOR
THE STATE PROBE. M. O. U. AND
CLOSE THIS BIT AND GIVE YOU
CORRUPT. ARE CLEANING AND
BROUGHT THREE PROGRAM IN THE
UNITED. OF EVIDENCE BY THE-
REPORTING YOUR BOTTOM. RIGHT
PROGRAMS ARE GOING THEY WERE TO
DO WHICH IS DIRECTOR WITH SMALL
AND EASY HE COMPANY GROW. ANY
MENTION OF. ASSEMBLY NOT TRUE
THE NUMBERS AND OUT OVER FOR.
THE BEEN ELEVEN SINCE THE LAST
OPTION GOING. AND HELP WHAT THE
LETTER MENTIONED WITH THE
INCREASE THE PAUL.
PROGRAM THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MR VICE OF MS CLIMB
BEFORE WE TAKE YOUR TESTIMONY WE
DID WE DID BECAUSE WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM. THIS VIDEO IF YOU COULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ARCHULETA
FIRST LETTER HERE GROVE EGGMAN
EGGMAN HERE MELENDEZ NEWMAN HERE
YOU MEN HERE ROTH ROTH HERE
AMBERG THEIR NUMBER HERE. WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM IS PRESENT-
MADELEINE KLEIN WITH THE
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
PLEASE- IF YOU COULD SUBMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY VIA THE CONFERENCE
LINE- AND WE WOULD ASK YOU TO
KEEP IT FAIRLY BRIEF AT THIS
POINT THANK YOU. YES OF COURSE-
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
ALLEN KLEIN ON BEHALF OF THE
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE CO SPONSORS
AND SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL- OKAY
MY COMMENTS BRIEF ARTICLE FUSION
WAS FOUNDED BACK IN TWENTY
NINETEEN IS MADE UP OF
TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES DEDICATED
TO BUILDING BETTER PARTNERSHIPS
WITH THE STATE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. OUR SMALL
BUSINESS AND DVD MEMBERS CAME TO
US ASKING OUR ASSOCIATION TO
WEIGH IN. ON THE SB DVD PROGRAM
AND HELP EXPAND UTILIZATION FOR
THE SMALL BUSINESSES AND THE
COMMUNITY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER AFTER
THE TREATMENTS CARE OPTION THE
RATE FROM THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
TAKE PATH. A WHICH IS NOT AN
INCREASE IN. TWO THOUSAND TEN.
AGAIN WE'RE PLEASED WITH THE%
EXCUSE TEN EIGHT JUST HELP
IMPROVE SB THE- PRO. I UPDATE
THE IS THE OF CONTACT OFF RAMP
MAYBE YEAR. I REQUIRE SPECIFIC
GUIDANCE THE RELEASE TO HELP
DEPARTMENT S. U. I. FOR. TOOL IN
USE OF THE FOR BOTH THE STATE
AND STD V. COMMUNITY. I THINK
YOU'RE CENTER ARE TO LOT OF
CROSS AT THE FOURTEENTH EIGHT
AND HAPPY ANSWER QUESTIONS MAY
ARISE. INTO YOU MAY KLEIN LET'S
GO BACK TO THE COMMITTEE HERE
OVER THERE WITNESSES PRESENT
HEARING ROOM LIKE TO TEST INTO.
OF S. B. SAID EIGHT. SEEING HERE
MISS MY IF YOU. QUEUE THE- LIKE
FOR ANYWAY THIS IS. A SUPPORT.
OF THIS BILL. SAID FOURTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU EXPRESS
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE. AGAIN
THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO PLEASE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LEARN
ONLINE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU LET'S GO BACK TO
HEARING WITH ANY WITNESSES HERE
LIKE TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION.
TO SB FORTY SEVEN YEAH. AND
SEEING NONE I MISS MODERATOR FOR
IF WE PLEASE QUEUE THE TELECOMS
LINE FOR ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU DESPITE
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE. AGAIN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. EIGHT I APOLOGIZE IF
YOU'VE CALLED IN AS A PRESENTER
A WITNESS FOR ANOTHER BILL
YOU'RE UNABLE TO REACH THE QUEUE. THERE ARE NO LINES IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME PRECIADO THANK YOU SO
COMING BACK TO COMMITTEE ROME A
ANY MEMBERS COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE
TO. MAKE A COMMENT OR OTHERWISE
ASK A QUESTION ON THE BILL. GOT
A MOTION FROM SENATOR EGGMAN-
TO- MISTER ARTS WHAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. HERE THANK YOU
FOR TAKING OVER AND I
APPRECIATED. COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND- ALL THE BETTER JOB THERE
THANK YOU FOR SUPPORTING THIS
BILL. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE BUT- I THANK YOU MISTER
DELIVERY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA I GROVE EGGMAN EGGMAN
AYE MELENDEZ. NEWMAN AYE NEWMAN
AYE ROTH. ROTH AYE AMBERG AYE
AMBERG AYE. THANK YOU. IT BILLS
OUT OVER TO THE GALLERY THE TO
THE CHAIR CENTER TO AND I THINK
WE'VE GOT THE- JUST. CALL THE
ROLL. YEAH OKAY THE CONTINUE-
DID WE DO THE- THE CONSENT
GALLAGHER LET'S GO WITH CONSENT
CALENDAR. OKAY WELL WE'VE BEEN
ON CALL THEM RIGHT. CYNTHIA OKAY
I'VE GOT A MOTION THE CONSENT
GALLAGHER ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEMS AS THESE NINE
FOUR NINE SB TEN SEVENTY THREE
SB ELEVEN NINETY FIVE SB TWELVE
THIRTY SEVEN LAST YEAR FIFTEEN
AG ARE FIFTEEN. SB NINETY FOUR.
SB THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN SB.
FOURTEEN THIRTY FIVE. EXCUSE ME
H. E. R. TWENTY EIGHT. ARCHULETA
YES YES I AGRO EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE
MELENDEZ NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE ROTH
ROTH AYE AMBERG BUT FROM BURKE I
. THE BILL THAT WE CAN LEAVE IT
OPEN OKAY THANK YOU ONE. AS WELL
SO THEY- OKAY. YEAH I'D LIKE MY
SECOND I'LL MAKE THE MOTION OKAY. WE HAVE A MOTION ON THIRTEEN
ELEVEN. SB THIRTEEN ELEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED FOR
THE FIRST AMEND AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS. ARCHULETA OR
SHOW A HIGH GROWTH EGGMAN EGGMAN
AYE MELENDEZ. NEWMAN HUMAN AYE
ROTH. HI NUMBER. CENTER NUMBER.
WE CAN LEAVE IT OUT COMPLETELY.
SO WE'LL KEEP EVERYTHING ON
FAULTY WE GET- THE OTHERS BACK
IN. AND WE'LL TAKE A BREAK. OKAY.
LADIES IN GENERAL RECESSED STILL
SEVEN MINUTES AFTER THREE. THANK
YOU.
IT COMMITTEE ON MILITARY
VETERANS AFFAIRS WILL NOW OPEN
AND- WE WILL GO AHEAD AND BEGIN
TO CLOSE- WE HAVE BEEN INFORMED
WE CAN CLOSE SO LET ME GO AHEAD
AND DO THAT NOW AND LIKE TO
THANK YOU ALL- INDIVIDUALS AND
EVERYONE WHO PARTICIPATED TODAY
IN THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR GESTURES IN WRITING
TO COMMITTEE. VETERANS AFFAIRS
OR VISIT SINCE THE JET. PORTENT
TO US AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE
YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU AND
THANK EVERYONE FOR PARTICIPATING
TODAY AND AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA. THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON MILITARY VETERANS AFFAIRS IS
HEREBY ADJOURNED.